it's really good to see everyone I wish
it wasn't just the dark times and
brought us together
the man you're looking for is Vandal
Savage oh isn't it immortal you're not
going to get rid of them watch us think
it's what makes them all heroes
/
hey youtubers it's Charlie so we got a
new flare Oh trailer I'm gonna break it
down and we have info on the midseason
finales for arrow in the flash so let's
get going
the big thing that's different from last
year is is that like the entire cast
from the flash will go on arrow during
the flash episode Vandal Savage comes
after Hawkgirl when she's with Cisco
Cisco takes her to STAR Labs explains to
everyone how he bides on her and they go
to Oliver and team arrow for help when
they're in Star City Hawkman comes out
of nowhere and steals off with Hawkgirl
now at this point in the story she has
no idea who she is like you know she's
hanging out with Cisco just thinking
she's a regular barista
so he has to explain to her what their
heritage is the whole idea of
reincarnation the fact that she has
wings she can fly so it's about her
figuring out that she has these powers
as you see from the trailer in addition
there is some zoom stuff happening the
episode itself is called legends of
today the arrow part of the crossover is
called legends of yesterday so you get
the idea it's a play on the title
legends of tomorrow and the zoom stuff
that's happening on the flash part of
it's really cool this will freak you
guys out Harrison wells
comes up with another speed serum that
will allow Barry to run faster but he
wants to test it out on Jay Garrick
first now doesn't that just scream
edward clariss from the classic Golden
Age flash comics now in case you didn't
recom exterminate Garrick era the
reverse flash of his era was named
edward clariss
he developed this serum that allowed him
to run as fast as the flash and so he
became what was known as the rival later
in the comics that character looked like
a shadow version of Jay Garrick with
Blue Lightning so just add that to your
list of zoom theories like a dark
version of Jay Garrick
but then on the air a part of the
crossover team arrow team flash take
Hawkman and Hawkgirl to another secret
location to hide out from Vandal Savage
get Merlin's help Merlin's not going to
sit on the bench during big two-hour
crossover he ends up being a go-between
for FanDuel savage but while that's all
going down Laurel Diggle Thea Felicity
and the other people from team flash
develop a weapon to take down Vandal
Savage
or at least neutralize him because he's
gonna be the big bad for legends of
tomorrow so they're not gonna be able to
kill him but the real question is is
what does Vandal Savage want from
Hawkgirl so bad that he attacks her in
the first part of the crossover my
thought is is what they've done is
because he's immortal
hawkman hawkgirl essentially immortal -
or at least they get keep getting
reincarnated that he wants her tenth
medal for those that haven't read any
Hawkman or Hawkgirl comics the enth
metal is this thanagarian mineral that
their gear is made of it has a bunch of
magical properties allows them to fly
it's just it's the most amazing metal
you could ever imagine
next to dwarf star alloy so either
Vandal Savage could be after that or it
could have something to do with the
curse of reincarnation now they've
changed Hawkman and Hawk girl's
backstories a little bit across the
comics so I'm just assuming that they're
gonna dovetail Vandal Savage with their
origin story here's my
question for you guys let me know in the
comments below what do you think that
Vandal Savage wants from Hawkgirl do you
think it's the enth medal that he wants
or is it something else but in addition
to that whatever temporary victory they
win against Vandal Savage I'm expecting
a rip hunter cameo at the end and I
think that legends of tomorrow is gonna
start episode 1 whenever arrow and flash
come back in January that's usually like
the third week in January
they said the show's gonna start at the
beginning of the year that just that
makes the most sense it'll probably just
air on a different night that show is
only supposed to be like 13 to 16
episodes that they haven't decided
exactly how many episodes it's gonna be
what's gonna happen next is because
arrow and flash are on break next week
but there's heroes and villains fan fest
this weekend
Stephen Amell said they're bringing
something extra cool I think they're
gonna debut new footage so next week
I'll totally do a video for whatever new
trailer footage they bring and if you
guys haven't heard me talk I've been
talking about it all week Jessica Jones
is dropping midnight tonight I'll be
doing all kinds of crazy videos so be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
I might do one last Jessica Jones
trailer video I have a whole bunch of
footage I might do like one last video
before the series premieres
I don't know internationally I'm not
sure what time it's gonna drop
internationally so if you live in Great
Britain or you live in Australia or
somewhere else I'm not exactly sure so
you'll just have to double check on the
time while you guys wait for everything
to post you can click here for this
week's episode of the Flash's arrow and
you can click here for the Star Wars
trailer and just post it whole bunch of
thin lightsaber action is so awesome so
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight